welcome back I'm Alex lion this is
lesson three of seven in the course in
this lesson I want to give you a little
warning a little heads up a lot of
people give push back on this particular
strategy that you're going to see where
I talk about using plain English plain
language to express yourself it's one of
the most valuable ways to make your
messages more clear more concise and
more confident and yet some people
resist they want to keep in the
sophisticated complicated language so if
you feel that you're in that crowd if
you're if you're one of those people
that doesn't want to do that then check
your self talk figure out what it is
that's going on in your mind and address
it because again all the tips in the
world are not going to change the way
you ultimately communicate unless you
figure out what's happening internally
that's driving your communication so
let's Jump Right
[Music]
In in our last lesson we looked at how
to form a concise overall message in
lesson three we'll look at concise
senten
concise tip number three is use short
sentences Oliver Wendell Holmes a
well-known judge from about 100 years
ago said speak clearly if you speak at
all carve every word before you let it
fall there a very poetic way to say you
want to work on short sentences and
express yourself concisely short
sentences pop they sound much more
confident more concrete and much more
memorable than long-winded sentences
they sound like news headlines topics
sentences of paragraphs items in a
bulleted list and on line jokes a lot of
times people will develop a nice clean
crisp way of communicating and it sounds
much more confident than long-winded
demanding sentences so you want to use
as few words is
possible strategy number one shave words
comedian Jerry Seinfeld talks about how
longer jokes are very hard to make funny
and it's they're much funnier when you
shorten the jokes and make them pop he
was talking about length of jokes and he
said if it's too long just a split
second too long you will shave letters
off of words you count syllables to get
it just right it's more like songwriting
and when he says songwriting he's
referring to how songwriters have to fit
their words into a certain beats and
they will have to come up with creative
ways to express themselves in very few
words so Seinfeld has a joke about
Pop-Tarts where he really practices what
he preaches he says about Pop-Tarts they
can't go stale because they were never
freshh which is hilarious but it's
amazing how he can communicate that in
so few words and there's not a single
extra letter in this punchline they
can't go stale because they were never
fresh he doesn't say they will never go
stale or they can never go stale that
would be too many words you can't go
stale cause instead of because cause
they were never fresh there's not I
can't think of anything that I would
shave off of this and it's much funnier
because of it the lesson here is you
want to get rid of the Clutter so your
sentences sound more concise and and
more confident so which sentence sticks
with you we look at two samples about
voting if you are bored and disgusted by
politics and don't bother to vote you
are in effect voting for The entrenched
establishments of the two major parties
who please rest assured are not dumb and
who are keenly aware that is in their
interest to keep you disgusted and Bor
and cynical and to give you every
possible reason to stay at home doing
one hitters and watching MTV on primary
day that's a very long sentence it's
going to be difficult to remember
what the message is here here's B if you
don't vote you don't matter which was
said by Sean pen in a movie about a
politician from the South if you're
asking me which line sticks if you don't
vote you don't matter stuck with me for
years after I saw that movie one time
now I don't know if the politician he
was playing actually said that or if the
people who wrote the movie Just crafted
it but it's a well-crafted sentence and
again there's not a single extra letter
or word in that sentence that's why it
sounds so confident whether you agree or
disagree with the sentiment it sounds
confident and it really
pops so let's shave the Clutter to make
this sound like a headline a few things
came up complications I guess you could
call them that are going to cause some
unforeseen delays and I'm not sure if we
can get it all done by Wednesday now we
might I'm just saying that we're going
to have to see what happens and play it
by ear how could we shave this clutter
to make it sound much more like a news
headline if it were were me I would do
it this way I'm not sure if we can get
all done by Wednesday now we might you
could even reword it slightly I'm not
sure if we can get all done by Wednesday
because of
delays is there anything else we could
shave from this sentence shave a few
more words like Seinfeld what would he
do I think probably he would take the
extra few words out that he could and
that would make it sound even more
concise and confident let's try another
one let's shave the Clutter what do you
recommend we do when we visit Rhode
Island well let's see I'd say probably
the most amazing place I mean it's
really amazing as long as the weather is
good is the beach in Rhode Island
because that's what we're known for and
it's not called the ocean state for no
reason so this is a pretty long answer
for a very short question what do you
recommend we do and if it were me I
would shorten this all the way down and
get rid of almost everything and I would
say the most amazing place is the
beach can we shave this even further
well we might be able to
but you don't want to overcorrect and
shave it down to single words I think if
you asked someone this question and they
answered the beach that might sound a
little too clipped and a little
dismissive so you make sure you form
full Thoughts full sentences and you're
going to be on safe ground strategy
number two use plain English a lot of
people perhaps to sound smart perhaps
because they love language will dress up
what they say and unnecessarily comp
complicated vocabulary so you want to
avoid those kinds of bigger words
because they don't necessarily add a lot
of value utilize if you look it up it
just means use problematical just means
problem Academia is another way to say
college you want to use plain language
whenever you can because every once in a
while there'll be a thought you can't
possibly Express plainly and you want to
leave room in your sentences for that
more sophisticated idea and to do so you
want to simplify everything else that
you can into very plain English I
actually have heard a lot of people
coming up through grad school use the
word problematical and I just never
understood why they would use such a
demanding word so don't use flower
language when simple language will do
say it in plain English contemplate how
would you say this word contemplate how
would you translate that I would say
think commence is another fancy way to
say start and terminate is a fancy way
to say end now you don't have to do this
in every single case but in general to
be concise and to make to make nice
concise sentences you want to use plain
English let's say this one in plain
English I was reflecting on my position
I've altered my perspective on the
matter what's the person really saying I
think they're saying I changed my mind
and that's how you want to express
yourself there's no way to
misunderstand a nice plainly worded
sentence so use short sentences with as
few words as possible your takeaway
strategies are to shave the Clutter like
Seinfeld and other people who really
work on compressing those sentences and
use plain English whenever you can your
takeaway task here is to apply this in
conversations and Q&A in the next few
days and make a habit out of answering
with short concise sentences in our next
lesson we're going to look at how to
organize your thoughts clearly I look
forward to seeing you then